wir sind zurück und ich darf mit meinem
thema heute abend starten das ist markus
söder wer diese sendung verfolgt weiß
ich habe heute drei neue minister ein
neuer generalsekretär der bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten öffnet den csu
wahlkampf mit frischen gesichtern ja
angekündigt hatte markus sogar eine
verfeinerung seines kabinetts
herausgekommen ist ein minister beben
bayern hat nun insgesamt 30 minister für
mich zeigt dass austausch puzzle ganz
deutlich markus söder es getrieben vor
angst die landtagswahl im jahr 2023 zu
verlieren so der spricht von einer
schicksalswahl doch auch mit den neuen
köpfen wird ein hoher wahlerfolg bei der
landtagswahl doch hoffentlich nicht
gelingen denn die wichtigste personalie
die ausgetauscht gehört ist doch
populist markus söder selbst ich hoffe
dass die bayerischen bürger nicht
vergessen dass markus so dass corona
politik angerichtet hat menschen durfte
in münchen zeitweise nicht mehr allein
auf einer parkbank sitzen wurden gebeten
aufzustehen im freien musste maske
getragen werden und von den kindern
möchte ich jetzt gerade gar nicht erst
anfangen gerne nennt sich söder team vor
sich ich nenne ihnen lieber team
wählerstimmen das erklärt auch warum man
jetzt ja aufpassen kurs ist markus söder
gehört abgewählt
jüngste müsste analyse zu ich finde es
schön wenn
sie
etwas vorsichtiger verteidigung also ich
finde tatsächlich auch dass markus söder
auf die unangenehmste art und weise
profiliert hat
tatsächlich als autoritäre politiker
eines formats das eigentlich in einer
freiheitlichen demokratie
nicht richtig am platz ist ich würde
trotzdem mit einem punkt widersprechen
ich finde die tatsache dass er sozusagen
auch weiß aus rein pragmatischen treffen
wenn kurs gewechselt hat macht ihn
sympathisch mir ist ein populist
jederzeit lieber als ideologe und ich
finde was man tatsächlich da was
erwähnen kann ist das für einen kurs
nicht aus ideologischen gründen sondern
tatsächlich aus materialistisch
strategischen gründen gewechselt hat da
sehe ich grundsätzlich immer hoffnung
wenn leute überhaupt in der lage sind
auf stimmung zu reagieren deswegen ist
mein urteil jetzt nicht so vernichtend
was macht einen guten populisten denn
aus
einen guten populisten macht es
tatsächlich aus die stimmung erst mal in
der bevölkerung wie man ja sagt volk
sagt man ja nicht mehr so gerne früher
hätte man gesagt die stimmung im volke
zu erspüren und
und sein politisches handeln danach
auszurichten auszurichten und das finde
ich grundsätzlich sehr richtig ich
glaube auch dass schüler die stimmung in
der bevölkerung falsch eingeschätzt hat
in vieler hinsicht in der krise das hat
man gesehen dass seine popularitätswerte
peter nach unten gegangen sind diese
autoritäre kurs des quasi corona
generals und des großen machers der hat
in der regel mit mit harten verboten und
mit mit harten ansagen auch
politik gemacht hat der hat ja nicht so
richtig funktioniert also insofern ist
würde sicherlich noch nicht der perfekte
populist
also mittel mittelprächtiger populist
mittelprächtiger populist jetzt merke
ich mir für mich
nicht mehr popstars ich sage
mittelprächtiger populismus hört sie
auch direkt bei
seine ausgaben zu haben scheint und da
wir keine bagger keine aktien ich habe
keine aktien in bayern und als schweizer
ist natürlich der sehr zurückhält
zurückhaltend gehen dabei aber eine öko
ist ein populist ein populist ist sie
haben sich ein politiker der immer das
sagt was das publikum gerade hören
möchte und ist eigentlich ein schlechter
politiker ein politisches oder gewisse
grundsätze haben und die heute vertreten
auch unabhängig von der zusammensetzung
seines publikum so mein eindruck von
markus söder ist gab es ein hobby ist ja
ist verwandlungskünstler und diesen
karneval spektakeln dritte 100%
verkleidet als kiss gitarrist aus
schreien jetzt nicht auch noch
kritisieren
das ist eine ich merke die runde ist
übermotiviert fällt mir vor ein anderer
er hat so eine fähigkeit als
verwandlungskünstler und ich glaube das
ist ein bisschen das problem von ihnen
das ist auch das was dich stört hier wo
beide vorhaben natürlich mit der krone
politik von ihm ihr gehabt und wenn
nicht im von außen betrachten würde ich
sagen es populistisch ist für mich zu
wenig csu-politiker war mit der csu habe
ich immer identifiziert einem franz
josef strauß so saft wurzeln die dann
bei ganz bestimmten themen
unverrückbarer fels in der brandung war
und wenn ich mit leuten aus bayern
spreche dann habe ich viele kritik
gehört auch an leute die gesagt haben
denn ist uns zu wankelmütig heute
umarmte die bäume morgen spielt er bei 1
bei corona dann ist er wieder der erste
der den der die impfpflicht fordert dann
wieder der letzte der sie aufhebt und so
weiter also ich glaube das ist ein
beispiel geben für populismus im nicht
guten sinne quasi eben man sagt einfach
das was das publikum hören möchte
populär das ist gut wenn du natürlich
populär bist aber populismus da gibt es
viele aber meistens sind die die als
populisten bezeichnet werden das sind
gar nicht die populisten frau merkel war
auch eine populistische india darauf dem
wirt aus wieder erzählt was das publikum
mit dem philippe bozon ist
ja okay dann müsst ihr euch jetzt schon
dank passieren sachen finanzen geladen
hackl und alle hatten
die
liste der vorwürfe an ja ich finde also
ich muss bei einem sagen ich finde er
war jetzt zu anfang ab anämie der
beliebteste oder einer der beliebtesten
politiker und ich finde im gegenteil ich
war auch er will man sich in teams
eingeteilt vorsicht und ich finde er hat
das eben rüber gebracht mit einer ruhe
und einer entschlossenheit die glaube
ich bei ganz vielen für ruhe gesorgt
haben in den anfängen der pandemie ich
fand es entblößen dass er nachdem er
eine woche zuvor gesagt hat er steht für
die impfpflicht und mir schon gesagt
nein könnte schwierig werden weil man
muss sich vielleicht irgendwie fünfmal
boostern und wie will man das eigentlich
umsetzen und man sieht schon irgendwie
buckles an allen ecken nein an einer ist
er wirklich dafür und ich glaube eine
woche nach diesem gespräch so weil dubai
also impfpflicht für pflegekräfte machen
wir jetzt leider doch nicht nee also bin
ich wirklich dagegen da war es da dachte
ich so moment mal so hart für mich die
fassade nicht gebröckelt das macht so
guten warum und alles war
zusammengefallen sich das im moment mal
also dieses wortbruch war ziemlich
offenkundig und der zweite fehler glaube
ich den er gemacht hat ist dass er nicht
während des wahlkampfs ich weiß jetzt
gegen ein bisschen zurück von weg von
corona aber dass er nicht einmal ehrlich
gesagt hat wisst ihr was ich sehe das
jetzt mit dem laschet ich wollte nie
sagen aber ich schmeiße zimmermann gut
ins rennen ich würde das machen ihr
wollt mich eh alle ich kann es besser
wollen wir nicht doch und ich glaube das
hätte zu einer glaubwürdigkeit
beigetragen ich weiß gar nicht wann es
endlich ausgegangen wäre aber ich glaube
die rolle zu spielen zu sagen danke ich
will dich ich habe schon bayerns ist
super aber der macht wirklich wahnsinnig
schlecht hätte er mich gefragt ich
glaube das hat ihm keinerlei sympathie
punkte eingebracht aber jetzt
also wird zumindest mal eine these
aufgreifen wenn man sagt populäre
politiker muss man sagen natürlich hat
er markus söder kriegt jetzt viel druck
ab aber er ist nach wie vor enorm
beliebter ministerpräsident und hat hohe
zustimmungswerte und man muss vor allem
eins sagen jetzt kann man natürlich
sagen es gibt andere die sind da
vielleicht ein stück weit er
ideologischer uns in den worten zu sagen
aber ich habe markus söder immer als
unglaublich professionell wahrgenommen
und natürlich kann man sagen ja klar der
korrigiert jetzt häufiger seine meinung
als andere aber ich finde er ist schon
jemand der durchaus auch in persönlich
nur in seiner kommunikation dann super
hohen grad an professionalität hat und
auch immer den blick nach vorne da dürft
auch was jetzt die personalentscheidung
angeht weil das war ja so ein bisschen
der anlass für die these heute na ja da
hätte jetzt auch eine kabinettsumbildung
gemacht nein das ist nicht so ich glaube
das ist wirklich ein gutes personalpaket
gewesen zeigte dass es weniger frauen
dabei sind es vor fünf jahren hat er
sich noch gefreut hat gesagt cases
halbe-halbe jetzt endlich erwarte bei
zwölf minister achso 3 in frauen ok ja
hat er das ganze richtig nach vorne also
dann kann ja wenn man jetzt sagt die
kernthese dieser kabinettsumbildung sei
die herstellung von parität im
bayerischen kabinett ja wie gerne ich
glaube hasen verlieren die schon ab ich
glaube jedenfalls dass in der
entscheidung die vor allem für berlin ja
auch relevant dass die frage
generalsekretär hat eine sehr sehr gute
entscheidung getroffen mit meinem
kollegen stephan mayer der vorher
staatssekretär im innenministerium eine
top professionelle
personalie markus blume ist ein minister
geworden und ich war das schlecht
gemacht hat als generalsekretär sein
weil er da sehr erfolgreiche arbeit
gemacht hat und ich finde jedenfalls aus
der sicht sozusagen der die kollegen da
auch kennt ist es eine sehr
professionelle kabinettsumbildung ich
glaube deine kritik wagte auch er daran
dass du natürlich insgesamt mit der
korona politik nein
mit dem zukunftsteam das zukunftsteam
hatte für mich auch wann immer er die
bande oder aber jetzt wollen wir neue
gewicht jetzt gibt es hunde eigentlich
die neuen gesichter ich kann das gar
nicht so schlecht denn jetzt
mit dem besten ergebnis im
bundesvorstand gewählt und einer aus
diesem zukunftsthema ist jetzt partei
und fraktionsvorsitz weil nämlich werz
und finde ich eher stärken so schnell
unter diesem zukunftsthema doch der
entschied der welt vor augen aber auch
noch eine andere frage worauf sich auch
meine meinem ein statement dazu dass er
jetzt angst hat übrigens auch beruft und
zwar die die werte man jetzt auch nicht
so gut für die union in bayern oder wenn
wenn du sagst inzwischen oder hat euch
das ergebnis in bayern so gefreut union
also zur wahrheit gehört natürlich dass
wir zu dem ziel der absoluten mehrheit
was man gebetsmühlenartig vor sich trägt
da ist natürlich noch ein weiter weg
aber ich glaube der markus söder wird
zur landtagswahl schaffen da auch gut
abzuschneiden und natürlich konnte sich
ja auch niemand entkoppeln auch vom
allgemeinen bundestrend auch in bayern
konnte man das nicht aber wenn alle
landesverbände der cdu so gut
abgeschnitten hätten wie die csu in
bayern wäre es glaube ich auch ein
besseres bundestagsergebnis kann muss er
immer damit vergleichen was auch schon
früher möglich ist auch der anspruch und
wir arbeiten uns ja langsam in die
richtung wieder programm ein
mehrwert und kämpft also 4 gegen einfach
gut gemacht philipp und jetzt gehen wir
auch direkt an den könig